[موسيقى]
عندما يفكر الناس بدبي اليوم اول ما
يتبادر الى الذهن هو اطول برج في العالم
او الفندق الايقونه وفي ظل برج العرب ياخذ
حدث مختلف مجراه وكله يحوم حول الفن هذه
هي السنه الثامنه لارت
[موسيقى]
دبي وايضا هي السنه الرابعه لانطونيا
كارفر مديره المعرض يعتبر ارض دبي معرضا
فنيا رائدا في المنطقه وهنا هنا اكثر من
85 جناحا يعرض فيها اعمال فنيه مختلفه مع
التركيز بشكل خاص على الفن الحديث في
الشرق الاوسط خلال القرن ال 21 هذه محاوله
لابعاد فكره ان دبي مركز للتجاره فقط بل
هي مدينه ذات تراث المعرض جزء واحد فقط من
مظاهر انتشار الفن والتراث في الامارات
فمن المتوقع افتتاح متحف لوفر في ابو ظبي
في عام
2015 اصبح الفن الحديث شعبي للغايه فقد
كرسوا مكانا مخصصا له هنا في ارض دبي نبيل
نحاس فنان لبناني يسكن في نيويورك وقد ترك
بلده عندما كان في ال من عمره ليدرس الفن
في
امريكا وبينما يقام هذا المعرض مره في
السنه الا ان الفنانين يقررون البقاء هنا
في هذا
البلد